yeah welcome to this video yeah let's go
D for me playing agent zero from Turkey
hmm
can I do my let's play g3 I'm trying to
get ya okay we got a Queen's Indian I
was thinking a Catalan but okay the
Queen's in unison very common
transposition kec4 like no yeah
castles normally yeah here there are
couple of moves you can play 93 years my
father
the main move it is usually answered by
94 you can also play d5 pawn sacrifice
yeah I don't really know that I know a
couple of couple of ideas but it's not
like I'm an expert the ideas after
taking that white plays Knight to each
form and he intends to bring this Knight
to f5 to count exactly like this
and the idea is not going to f5 and also
irritating him a bit with this structure
it was c6 and white is God's very active
night and Bishop on g2 the extra bonus
the deep horn and it's not so clear or
if you want the c6 bomb these are the
extra pounds and they're not so easily
moved without leaving some substantial
weaknesses so my next move is probably
formed d4 Knight c3 Bishop f4 Quincy for
those kind of active moves Knight f6 is
rare moves I think here they all go
night to c7 sooner or later yeah okay
come on let's let's play a form it
should be should it be too bad I wonder
what about e5 now immediately yeah
if I've this looks strong
because I have queen g4 as an incident
follow-up
hmm I thought I thought 97 pleased
attacking in five here John Quincy Frey
needs to play g6 which is really really
ugly but it needs to do that
probably
hmm yeah it's still not not easy let's
check some some direct ideas taking on
e4 this is some idea probably not
hmm should I try to exchange the night
with Knight c3 maybe I can go Queen G
for later anyway a bishop CA tone sounds
one one possibility
yeah I don't really know let's let's
provoke g6 first the Sun is a weakness
no doubt about that
I know it's it's it's very difficult g6
yeah he threatens maybe Bishop c8 after
g6 pinning the tonight so I need to do
something I cannot simply M continue and
hope and good things happen okay play g6
like if you take simply taking this yeah
major let's simply weaken that's weaken
the dark squares it is it's not that's
not stupid Knight c3 take taking even
getting rid of this and then Knight c3
putting everything it's playing 94 I
mean 94 to have six okay let's try this
to play form for the dark squares and if
he captures I simply hope that this is
it's not possible and there's too much
like Bishop f4 ok he instantly takes
and maybe you can play Queen Queen h5 or
something yeah this um I don't know
I hope to get Getti fall back soon
Joseph that's my phone so how to get
this back be rookie 195 I take take
before and then I threaten Knight f6
that came
yeah that wasn't wasn't great what what
I played here
and this is putting it mildly
probably
that's some approach the g7 square this
is of course true points down and it's
not clear at all if anything
yeah it should to deform the lights
quite a bit the the dark squared bishop
is the only hope for some for some play
him I'm down to 35 seconds here this was
silly yeah I spent far too much time and
even making bad moves the combination is
is not not very promising if you click
that bad leave and play at least quickly
this is a common bits recipe for lots of
people just dash out some moves I'd
hoped for the best but to spend lots of
time and play crappers is never working
yeah I don't have anything yet
of course I have no way to avoid any
kind of Perpetual here on the on the
Queen time warning
this is a blonde check check check check
check check check
yeah this was 100% luck of course yeah
it was was completely completely lost a
minute I didn't even have time to to
think about if I should resort the game
I'm just I'm just an exchange down and
what about two pawns or something
simply um yeah he's backing up all the
moves I'm not sure probably is taking
only for scrap I don't know
multiple ways to improve on this game I
think yeah thanks for watching anyway I
need some luck once in a while as well